ja diese Spritztour die sorgt für
mächtig Ärger ein 600 PS Luxusschlitten
spektakulär geschrottet wir sehen hier
die Bilder die beiden jungen Insassen
die kommt zum Glück leicht verletzt
davon aber für diesen Blechschaden da
wird zumindest der Fahrer ordentlich
blechen müssen
600 unbändige PS treffen auf 25
unerfahrene Jahre dieser 125.000 Euro
Sportwagen Schrott ein 25-jähriger und
ein 600 PS Sportwagen eine Kombination
die am Abend in Hamburg nicht
zusammenpasst aufregennasser Straße
verliert der junge Fahrer die Kontrolle
über seinen Mietwagen rutscht in einer
Linkskurve von der Straße rasiert
mehrere massive Bäume ab kommt erst nach
20 Metern in einem Waldstück zum stehen
für so eine inhaltliche Straße mit 50
kmh
zulassen zugelassener
Höchstgeschwindigkeit ist es schon
beachtlich dass der Pkw von der Straße
abgekommen ist nach 20 Metern ca im
Grünstreifen zum Stehen gekommen ist und
dabei auch mehrere massive Bäume
umgeschlagen hat abrasiert hat kann man
wirklich so sagen ob das wirklich 50
km/h waren wird der Verkehrsunfalldienst
genauer herausfinden aber es ist davon
auch zu gehen dass es mir etwas mehr war
der Wagen komplett zerstört die Wucht
des Unfalls immens überall Trümmerteile
ein abgerissenes Rad nicht der erste
Crash an dieser Stelle
im letzten Jahres
mit einbeziehen
sind da schon von da aus kommend dagegen
Gefahren gegen die Bäume nicht da sieht
man da auch er hat doch ganz schön und
die Straße ist ihnen unbekannt und sind
da gerade ausgefahren sozusagen der
25-Jährige kommt mit leichten
Verletzungen davon seine 23-jährige
Schwester landet mit mittelschweren
Verletzungen in einem Krankenhaus die
richtig großen Bäume hat der PKW zum
Glück verfehlt zusätzlich kommt hinzu
dass es sich bei diesem PKW um ein sehr
modern
im Oberklassewagen handelt so dass
dieser auch entsprechend die Patienten
die Insassen vor weiteren Schaden ganz
gut geschützt hat mit einem anderen
Modell mit einem niedrigen Modell wäre
das Ganze garantiert anders ausgegangen
[Musik]